des girafes des ourant outoutant ou
encore des zèbres comme chaque année les
naissances sont nombreuses au ZooParc de
beauauval des naissances très encadrées
notamment par un programme européen pour
permettre à chaque espèce de perdurer
dans des lignes saines décryptage de la
reproduction en parc avec Hélène
chapelet chaque année près de 900
naissances ont lieu aux EAU de Beauval
parmi les petits nouveaux Sophie et
tiaya de girafons né à 10 jours
d'intervalle fin septembre et début
octobre à cause du mauvais temps et des
risques de chute tout le monde a été
temporairement rentré Ariel la
responsable de la plaine africaine en
profite pour les gâter un
peu du coup Sophie sa maman c'est baaya
qui est juste derrière là-bas en marron
clair et puis tissaya du coup sa maman
c'est Binty qui est en train de manger
juste là les petites girafes vont rester
chez nous jusqu'à l'âge de 4 ans l'âge
où elles vont arriver à peu près à
maturité sexuelle euh après là on va
avoir plusieurs possibilités ou elles
vont partir dans un autre parc ou elles
vont rester chez nous mais il va falloir
changer le le papa puisqu'elles ne
peuvent pas se reproduire évidemment
avec leur papa mais ça après ce ne sont
pas des décisions en fait qui nous
reviennent à nous c'est le coordinateur
en fait de l'espèce qui lui décidera les
naissances ne sont en effet pas laissées
au hasard si la reproduction de chaque
espèce se fait de manière naturelle
c'est-à-dire sans insémination c'est un
coordinateur qui décide des mises en
contact entre animaux en fonction de
leurs données génétiques à échon
européen il y a un coordinateur avec un
conseil d'administration un représentant
par pays et c'est le coordinateur qui
nous recommande
d'ou animal afin d'assurer une diversité
génétique suffisante à éviter toute
hybridation entre sous-espèces bien sûr
et surtout toute
consanguinité le reste de l'année les
animaux sont placés sous contraception
où les mâles sont séparés des femelles
pour les visiteurs qui viennent en
famille au parc voir des bébés c'est
forcément
attendrissant c'est très attrayant de de
voir les les bébés dans bah notamment
dans leur milieu soit les enclos comme
là on peut les voir de tout près ou même
des fois un petit peu plus loin dans le
parc ça ça attire l'œil quoi je crois
que c'est la vie les enfants donc on est
attendri tout
simplement 35000 animaux vivent dans les
encloss du zo au parc de Beauval le lieu
ouvert aux visiteurs toute
l'année